hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown the
international community speaking out
against the taliban's brutal actions
since their swift takeover in
afghanistan as the u.s withdrew from the
country fox news foreign correspondent
trey yinks reflects on his time in
afghanistan before during and after the
afghan government's collapse and his
experiences interacting with members of
the taliban
and across the nation housing prices
continue to rise real estate agent and
co-host of the hit hd tv show love it or
list it david byzantine sheds light on
the state of the housing market and how
the pandemic and the supply chain are
impacting the cost of homes and
renovations plus commentary by fox news
contributor and author molly hemingway
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm brett baer i'm maria bartiromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
friday october 15 2021 i'm chris foster
as a fox news foreign correspondent in
afghanistan trey yanks has gotten to
know the taliban a lot more than most
americans the unit that these fighters
came from
was a suicide bomb unit so most of the
guys running security at our hotel had
signed up to be suicide bombers where
they were roadside bomb makers
and now they were the people that you
literally saw
in line at the breakfast buffet
i'm jessica rosenthal the real estate
market's been on fire so have home
renovations is it all coveted related
and will it stay hot or cool off soon i
don't think it's going to dial back
um all that much you know i i just i
think people are always gonna want
housing it's just i don't i don't see it
changing
and i'm molly hemingway i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
trey yingst has been covering war zones
since college reporting on fighting
between israelis and palestinians in
gaza he came to work for fox news
channel as a foreign correspondent three
years ago based in jerusalem and has
been widely praised for his coverage in
afghanistan before during and since the
talibans take over the country and
american troop withdrawal we've just
arrived in kabul afghanistan where
evacuations are continuing at this hour
there are a number of people outside of
this hotel in kabul who worked for the
americans at the u.s embassy and they're
left behind
civilians outside of kabul grab for food
as a car with aid workers inside drives
by here at a children's hospital in the
afghan capital of kabul kids are being
treated for malnutrition just last month
five died here waiting for international
aid to arrive this commander from logar
province was in charge of a unit that
included suicide bombers roadside bomb
makers and combat fighters he says the
taliban fought too hard not to have
their laws put into practice as we speak
with this young law student at kabul
university a taliban fighter shows up
with a weapon in hand intimidating her
forcing us to abruptly end the interview
he spent a lot of time speaking with
taliban leaders spokespeople and
fighters while you have to remember who
these people are
you also have to remember that in order
to
have access to the group
you need to communicate with them and i
think that that's an important aspect of
of this story trey's been back home in
pennsylvania for a bit before getting
back to work in jerusalem he's also the
host of the fox news rundown evening
edition uh communicating with people
around the world good guys bad guys and
and everyone in between to let them know
what our role as journalists is our role
is not to help them or to make them look
good but it's also not to make them look
bad it's to report exactly what they do
and i'm always very clear with the group
when we have these conversations behind
the scenes
look we are going to report what you do
and if that involves cutting a peace
deal we will report that to the world
but if it involves killing civilians
we're going to report that too
yeah i mean you said good guys and bad
guys nobody's a bad guy in their own
story right i mean terrorists don't see
themselves as terrorists they see
themselves as you know fighting
honorably for some cause now what is the
cause for these guys is it is it
religious purity is it power is it money
or does it depends on who you ask
yeah i mean it's definitely based on
religion and land and you make a great
point that they don't see themselves as
the bad guys
people who signed up to be suicide
bombers
they believe they're doing the right
thing and that they're following the
religious education that they received
and that
this is ultimately what their purpose on
earth is
so
it can be very interesting talking to
them because
there's no
sort of western sense of of normalcy
when it comes to
what americans should be able to do and
where they should be able to operate
i think that
it's very interesting when you talk to
them because they say they're fighting
a
a war
an unconventional war maybe but a war
and these are the the weapons of choice
that they use
um i think
what i always try to cut through in
these conversations that we have
i try to cut through the noise of the
violence and sort of the propaganda
efforts by an organization like the
taliban they definitely want the world
to think that they are
peacemakers and and people who
are open to western values and and to a
society that would allow women to be
educated at the highest level and to be
treated as equals in society but it's
very important to
push back against those comments when
they make them because
they will say things like absolutely
women will have access to secondary
education but we saw with our own eyes
on the ground in kabul women being
blocked from entering kabul university
for example you saw it in the streets
there are very few women and those women
who were able to walk freely and operate
had to at least have a hijab on if not
an entire burqa so
it is one thing to to listen to what the
taliban says and it's a different thing
to observe their actions
it is just it's it's heartbreaking to me
thinking about
especially well all women in afghanistan
and girls in afghanistan but i'm
thinking about the young people who've
known nothing but the american
occupation and who've known the gains
that have been made over the last 20
years without the taliban in power
more women's rights more education more
freedom um and then of course the women
who had it before maybe older women who
lost it and then had it back and now
it's back to the bad old days as far as
they're concerned is it
what's your feeling about the women now
the girls there now
yeah i think it's a slippery slope right
now for women in afghanistan because
very slowly but surely the taliban will
implement their tribal interpretation of
sharia law
and their version of islam is not the
version of islam that we see all around
the world practiced by nearly 2 billion
muslims
it is a very
specific and extreme version of islam
and
within that framework
the taliban uses their views to restrict
the rights of women so
i think afghan women are extremely
afraid the ones that we spoke with in
in places like a beauty salon where we
actually went in and spoke with women
who
previously lived free
in afghanistan they were able to
walk around without covering their hair
and
and talk about their dreams and
aspirations as equal members of society
and that's just simply not the case
anymore and
i think back to the conversations we had
with women who just fled afghanistan we
talked to a group of university students
in qatar and they had just
exited an evacuation flight making it
safely out of the now taliban controlled
country
and
they were so concerned about their
degrees and their families and and
things that university women around the
world would be concerned about but yet
they're worried they'll never be able to
go back to the place that is home
and i think that on a very basic level
there are
are major fears about what comes next
for afghan women because there's very
little the international community can
do when it comes to the taliban the
sanctions are already in place the
international pressure is already there
but there are millions of afghan women
who will not have
as bright a future as they were
projected to have now that the taliban
is in control
the defense
by president biden and others who
advocated leaving the country was that
um
look we could have done this tomorrow in
a year and 10 years and 20 years this
was
it wouldn't have mattered so why why
spend more american blood and treasure
on this is that fair
the question that was
asked
throughout our coverage you know we
spent
more than 45 days in
afghanistan qatar and pakistan
in total reporting on this story
and the question that was asked over and
over again
should the united states have left
afghanistan
and i think in most conversations and
most officials that we talked to and
civilians who were experiencing this
firsthand
the question always shifted from
should the americans have left
afghanistan
to why and how did they leave in the
manner that they did okay
so there wasn't a question always of of
if the americans should have left it was
a question of how yeah and
i think it's
objectively
clear
that the way american forces left the
country
was not the best
possible choice and we see all these
reports coming out now that the taliban
was willing to cut some sort of deal
with the americans to allow u.s forces
to do security in kabul as these
evacuations started
and there were options still on the
ground and these are options that will
be debated and you will hear lawmakers
and military officials for weeks months
and years to come talk about this but
there were
things that the us could have done to
make this a much smoother and safer
process
um i want to talk about your training
your life people who might want to know
how this all works you've been doing
this for a long time for a pretty young
guy um talk about hostile territory
training if they still call it that um
things just
food places to sleep
yeah it's a question we actually get a
lot people say what did you eat where
did you stay and it changes based on the
story in this particular story we stayed
at a hotel in kabul
and it's a hotel where many foreign
journalists stay but the taliban was in
control of the hotel even so they did
security for the hotel while we were
there
and one interesting
sort of piece of this story the unit
that these fighters came from
was a suicide bomb unit so most of the
guys running security at our hotel had
signed up to be suicide bombers or they
were roadside bomb makers
and now they were the people that you
literally saw
in line at the breakfast buffet wow so
yeah
the people
people that would have people that would
have happily seen you dead
a year ago or now now their job is to
keep an eye on you
yeah and i mean they were very open
about that too they
said we would have killed you just
months ago
and
you talked to these fighters and and
there were similar stories across the
city i mean even at the airport i
remember there was one time where we
were sitting waiting to meet with a top
intelligence official at the airport to
get access to these
pieces of american military equipment
left behind and we were sitting with
these fighters for hours in this room
and just talking to them and they're a
similar age to to me i'm in their 20s
basically talking about their life
experience
and
they were talking about making bombs and
how they were disappointed that they
weren't chosen to be
suicide bombers
and they were very open about the fact
that they would have simply killed an
american had they been in the same room
this year earlier in the year so i think
that
it's a similar situation across
afghanistan now there are
taliban
fighters in control of the country and
when you talk about the security
situation i think it it's something we
calculate wherever we go you know we are
covering conflict zones around the world
whether it be in iraq in lebanon in gaza
and we face similar but changing threats
you always are dealing with humans and
emotions and i think that you always
have to keep that in mind when you're
talking to
extremists to militants to civilians to
anyone
that
people
sometimes make rash decisions very
quickly they make decisions based on
emotion you can be sitting in a room
with someone and suddenly they have a
memory
of something the americans did to one of
their family members and they could take
that out on you and you have to keep
that in mind
so everywhere you move
even in afghanistan i mean you're facing
threats from not just an extreme taliban
faction but groups like isis
other extremist organizations that may
want to target westerners and you have
to basically be calculating all the time
you have to be
totally tuned in and focused every
single day because one
wrong move could cost you your life
and you have to remember why you're
there because it can be very easy to get
consumed by the story especially when
you see things that
are really sometimes the most traumatic
events in someone's life you see a
parent lose a child you see people
searching for their loved ones
and you know the fate of these loved
ones you see malnourished children and
these
scenes and images
certainly have an impact on your mental
health and your
ability to cover a story but that's part
of our role as foreign correspondents to
go to the places that other people won't
go and tell those stories that otherwise
wouldn't be told
trey yanks fox news foreign
correspondent and host of the fox news
rundown evening edition trey it was
really good to talk to you um
welcome home i hope you have a nice day
before you head back overseas
thanks
[Music]
this is molly hemingway with your fox
news commentary coming up
even if you're not looking for real
estate right now you may have heard the
market's on fire the case-shiller home
price index increased nearly 20 percent
in july a fourth consecutive month of
record growth and the highest annual
rate of price growth since the index
began in the late 80s in august housing
starts increased by nearly four percent
this is a supply and demand issue
national home builder association ceo
jerry howard recently told fox's neil
cavuto
there are
40 percent fewer new homes on the market
this year than last year uh and with the
organic demand that's out there and
still very very strong
we've got some real real price pressures
and while september marked a high point
for inventory this year supply is still
on the slim side prices are so high it
may be keeping some people from moving
and instead they're renovating proof is
in the numbers home improvement finance
company hearth reported last month that
home repairs increased 82 percent over
the last two years with large increases
in spending on house painting plumbers
hvac and electricians
tension over whether to buy a new home
or renovate an existing one is at the
heart of the hgtv show love it or list
it lisa's had enough i don't want to
live in a construction zone and josh is
just getting started i fell in love with
all the possibilities i love a fun
project somebody's going to love it it's
just not gonna be me david byzantine's a
realtor and co-host of love it or listed
he says these real estate prices demand
and renovation increases all happen
during the pandemic for one thing the
market just went bonkers a new season of
the show is now airing on hgtv and
buying you know uh selling is easy
buying is hard i mean that's you know
that that's one of the
um
one of the key things that happened i
mean the market was
reasonably good prior to covid
and then shockingly
um
just got crazy after kovit
i still i still really don't realize you
know why um you know covet affected the
market the way that it did it made
absolutely no sense but it did
um
and what you have seen is you know over
the over the course of covid you know
people have been sort of using their
homes very differently um in a way that
they never did you know all of a sudden
you know you know people were like you
know creating spots for an office space
um or they were creating entertainment
areas you know with big screen tvs
because they weren't going to theaters
there was now a school zone area so kids
could be on zoom school and work from
there so all of a sudden that kind of
starts to you know affect
people's ideas in terms of renovations
that they should do
not just for their families but also to
add value
in terms of what you know they think
buyers might be looking for
um in this current
you know market and you know the way
life is currently
do you think these pandemic related
changes will last
i think there's a couple that will i
think you know i think people are going
to go out to restaurants you know and i
think people are going to still do that
um
you know i haven't been to a movie
theater
uh yet still
um and i don't i don't even know if i
will um
but um so i think the home theaters that
people are putting in will still
resonate uh for people um i i think
that's i think that's something that's
not going away even though people were
watching tv and they were watching
movies but now you go into you know a
lot of homes and people have got like
these theater rooms that are incredible
um and they were like you know few and
far between before before covert you
know the occasional you'd walk into a
house and be like oh my god they have a
home theater in here but now it's kind
of like almost like everybody does you
know everybody's turning their basements
into like these entertainment centers
you know where they can get together
with their family and sit down eat
popcorn you know and watch a you know a
major feature you know on their you know
80 inch tv
um
you know and i don't and i also don't
you know the home offices i think that's
going to continue because i think
there's a good section of people that
might not go back to offices and there's
corporations out there that i think have
seen what can be done
without office spaces that they have to
pay for
um and so a lot of those are going to
continue
so i think having a home office is going
to it's going to be something also that
you know that sticks
you're the listed guy on the show right
you're the you're the one pushing for
like let's put this up for sale did you
find that more and more people
wanted to love it wanted to renovate
well it's funny you know because we kind
of you know we although we we did a bit
of shooting through kovid um we were
down for a lot of it um because we
couldn't film the film industry did get
shut down so
i don't know that it affected the
numbers at all you know i think people
still need to have homes that work for
them and that they love
and if it's time to move it's time to
move and if you know um
and if it's not it's not
um you know but people are always going
to be so attached to their homes
especially if they've been in them
in them for 10 or 15 years you don't
need covet to make somebody you know
want to love it even though the house i
showed them makes more sense
um you know
but
that part but that that does affect it a
little bit but i don't i don't think
very much
not really i know you guys focused the
show for several seasons in north
carolina but i imagine you pay attention
to the real estate market everywhere and
you even referenced earlier in our own
interview that you you saw the real
estate market sort of catch fire during
the pandemic um is it on fire everywhere
is it gonna stay on fire i have this
theory right that when people really do
go back to work maybe in 2022 that the
the housing market might cool down a bit
am i wrong
i i would say that it kind of depends on
you know where you live
um you know certain certain cities are
just always going to be hot and you know
i mean even even within a city there's
you know there's these little micro
markets that never seem to never seem to
be not hot
i don't think it's going to dial back
um all that much
um you know i i just i think people are
always going to want housing it's just i
don't i don't see it changing what i am
seeing right now though is
is um you know in the major cities if
you go to the outskirts
it's not as hot as it was
it's already kind of taking a little bit
of a slower approach not that things
aren't selling
um it's just there's not the multiple
offer situations everywhere
that there was
so i do think i do think you're gonna
see a dial back in certain neighborhoods
um in certain areas
uh once once people you know are all
back at work in 2022 but i but i think
major cities like toronto new york all
of those ones
it's you know it's not going to slow
down i was reading rental prices in new
york and manhattan in particular have
skyrocketed um tell me renovations
depending on how involved they are can
cost quite a bit and
forget building a new house from scratch
that costs a lot as well it supplies and
we've been hearing about you know supply
chain shortages we've we've heard about
um
sawmill production you know being scaled
back because of covid and then when it
started to ramp back up again there was
like this backlog lumber prices went up
what have you seen or heard about um the
supply chain issue affecting real estate
and and even renovations
well getting stuff is really the tough
part you know everything getting wood
getting you know getting appliances um
you know and getting parts getting parts
for stuff is next to impossible um i was
i was building i was building a um
i have a hot tub in my backyard and i
was building this kind of trellis over
the top of it to give me a little bit of
shade
and um and so the guy who was doing it
for me
um was like david i just priced out the
wood
if you'd have done it last year it would
have cost you 10 times less do you still
want to do it
the the price of wood just went up so
dramatically and it's you know i
you know it's not price gouging it's
demand it's just there there wasn't
enough
um more people wanted it uh then there
was supply and that just happened and
it's dialing back now it's kind of
coming back down to earth um
but um
but it's it's made it tough it's made it
tough for renovations it's made it tough
for you know shows trying to get stuff
um it's definitely it's it's been it's
been a it's been a huge issue
let's talk about the future um you
talked about adding value to your home
what is the best way in your mind to do
that regardless of pandemic or not like
i've heard for example like with aging
baby boomers adding an addition or guest
house for your parents might be a good
idea you know is that realistic what are
some of the things you think of when you
think of a high value home
in this in this day and age if you're
building a you know any kind of an
in-law suite where your parents are
going to live the value is there i mean
you know it's invaluable i mean it's
just there's you can't even put price on
it um now when you go to sell it uh
you know is there demand
for in-law suites where you live
are you doing something that's out of
the norm in that neighborhood
and that's really i think what you've
got to look at when you're doing
anything beyond the obvious renovation
to the kitchen and the bathrooms that
everybody knows will add value um if
you're you know if you're if you've got
the space and you're adding another you
know an addition of a thousand square
feet um you know does
your neighborhood
allow for that you know and what you're
putting in will you get it back out
again
so you really kind of have to look at
where you are
and what your neighborhood will allow
for what's the ceiling in your
neighborhood currently
if you hold on to it for 10 or 15 years
you know then obviously that ceiling is
much higher
but if you're talking about an immediate
turnaround you kind of really have to
know and that's why i always tell people
whenever they're going beyond
um sort of
renovating a kitchen or renovating a
bathroom or adding a bathroom
when you're talking about adding you
know 1500 square feet to your house or
adding a two car garage or you know
putting in a you know a lap pool you
know look around at your neighborhood
and see what stuff is selling for and
see what people are offering and whether
it's feasible
because you can you can you can out
overdue your house in a neighborhood
david byzantine thank you so much for
your time
oh my pleasure my pleasure thank you
very much
[Music]
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
today marks 70 years since i love lucy
first hit tv screens in american
households it premiered on october 15
1951 and became the first series to air
in 10 million homes
six months after its debut it was the
number one show in america since then
it's aired in 77 different countries
been translated into multiple languages
and was named one of tv guide's best
series of all time its fans have endured
throughout the decades and many have
even traveled to the lucille bald desi
arnez museum which is located in
jamestown new york visitors can see
replica sets of lucy and ricky ricardo's
new york city apartment as well as their
california suite at the fictional
beverly palms hotel
in addition to seeing scripts wardrobes
and props on display
if you're planning a road trip there add
in some extra time to see the national
comedy center which is near the museum
and has exhibits with artifacts from
some of the most well-loved comedians
like jerry seinfeld and carol burnett
journey gunderson the executive director
of the museum and the center told fox
news quote what we see in both museums
every day are visitors leaving and
saying i never expected to laugh for
four hours straight
and who doesn't need that tanya j powers
fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind from 2016 through
2020 the easiest way to achieve stardom
on the political left was to loudly
proclaim one's belief that the 2016
election was illegitimate
stolen by the russians on behalf of a
corrupt traitor conspiracy mongering up
to and including the assertion that the
president of the united states was a
secret russian spy was the highest form
of patriotism
and then 2020 happened
at the drop of a hat america's electoral
system went from irredeemably corrupt
and broken in 2016
to unquestionably safe in 2020
voting methods that were allegedly used
to steal elections in 2004 and 2016
suddenly became sacrosanct and
unquestionable in 2020
whereas so-called election experts
repeatedly warned pre-2020 about the
pitfalls of electronic voting and
widespread mail-in balloting by november
2020 any discussion about the
vulnerabilities of those methods was
written off as the stuff of right-wing
cranks and conspiracy mongers
such dismissals required ignoring quite
real problems with election integrity
affecting hundreds of u.s elections at
the state and local levels and even the
1960 presidential election when john f
kennedy won just 118
574 more votes than richard nixon
that electoral college win hinged on
victories in illinois where chicago vote
totals were suspiciously high for
kennedy and texas a state where
kennedy's running mate lyndon b johnson
had been known to exert control over
election results
official biographers and historians have
claimed one or both states would have
been won by nixon in a fair election
if concerns about election integrity
were valid from at least 1960 through
2016
then surely those concerns were even
more valid in 2020 an election year
unlike any other in american history
in the lead-up to the election thanks in
part to the coronavirus pandemic that
gripped the world
wide-ranging electoral reforms were
implemented many changes allegedly
justified by the global pandemic were
broad reforms that democrats had long
desired the crisis was their chance to
sneak in contentious policies through
the back door
the bedrock of the american republic is
that elections must be free fair
accurate and trusted
election lawyers will tell you that
fraud is almost impossible to
conclusively find after the fact and
that to fight it strong rules and
regulations are needed on the front end
that's why democrats and republicans
fight so bitterly about the rules and
regulations that govern the process
what happened during the 2020 election
must be investigated and discussed
not in spite of media and political
opposition to an open inquiry but
because of that opposition the american
people deserve to know what happened
they deserve answers even if those
answers are inconvenient they deserve to
know the effect flooding the system with
tens of millions of mail-in ballots had
on their vote
they deserve to know how and why big
tech and the corporate political media
manipulated the news to support certain
political narratives while censoring
stories they now admit were true
they deserved to know why courts were
allowed to unilaterally rewrite the
rules in the middle of the contest
often without the consent of the
legislative bodies charged with writing
election
laws this has been an excerpt from
rigged how the media big tech and the
democrats seized our elections
i'm molly hemingway
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes